[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは私は今
コミュニケーションをどうデザインするか
という研究を行っています私が取り扱って
いるコミュニケーションは
言いづらいことのコミュニケーションです
今日はなぜ私がこのような活動しているの
かどうしてこういうことをやっているのか
そんなことについてお話しします
まず最初のきっかけは私がハッカーソンと
呼ばれものづくりに出会ったことでした
技術を学んで最新の技術でこんなことが
できるんだって分かった私はこれを
生理用品に転用したいと思いましたなぜ
ならば
男性の皆さんにはあまりわからないかも
しれないんですが
生理用品は
買うところから
使うところそして
管理をするっていうところまで
全部難しいんです一つ一つはすごく粗末な
ことなんですけれども
全部積み重なってしかも仕事が忙しくなっ
たりするともうとても管理ができませんな
のでここに技術の力を加えることで自動的
に管理ができて
便利にできるなっていうふうに思ってまし
た
そんな私が最初にやったことはこの問題
絶対全世界共通の話だよねっていうところ
でしたそういった思った私は
海外の事例を調べるんですそしたら
びっくりすることが2つありました
1つ目はいろんな国にすでに生理用品の
設置設備があったことなんです
2019年の私がプロジェクトを開始した
時点で日本の中では
自動販売機はあったんですが
総自動販売機は1枚しか必要じゃないのに
2枚
買わなきゃいけなくてかつその2枚も市販
価格の倍の値段がしていましたしかもその
生理用品は
誰もお店で見たことがないような生理用品
だったのでちょっと使うのが怖いなという
状態だったんですしかもすごく困っている
のに小銭がないと買えないんです
なので
結局トイレから出て小銭を作ってもう1回
戻るってことが必要でした
私とってもこれ不合意で非効率だなーって
思ってましたさて皆さんここでこのデータ
を見てみてください私が過去に実証実験で
撮ったデータです
生理用品がなくて
トイレに入り
生理だったということを気づいた時
皆さん
生理用品を必ず調達するんですがその
調達時間はなんと平均15分以上です
この時間とても無駄だと思いませんか
この時間は
別に
暇なときではない
仕事をしていたり
ランチに行く時間だったり
本当はその人にとって大事な時間のはず
です
で振り返って海外を見るとですね
海外には生理用品ディスペンサーがあった
んですまあ確かに
過去は有料でしたでも今はどんどん
どんどん無償化されてきて
誰でも生理になった人が
自由に使うことができるそんな設備が多く
の国にありました
そして2つ目です
2つ目はじゃあそんな
海外で使われている生理用品の設置設備
いつからあったんだろうすごくいいのに
これいつ
考えたのって思ったわけです
で調べてみたらこれも全くびっくりする話
だったんですけれどもなんと1920年代
のアメリカ製が発見されましたそれは今
アメリカの博物館に収納されています
1920年代といえば
第一次世界大戦が終わったぐらいの
タイミングです
この時代に
女性のリーダーがたくさんいたとは
ちょっと考えにくいと思ってますでも
男性のリーダーが
女性が
働きに出たり
学びに行ったりする時に生理があって困る
ことがあるだろうと
配慮されたものだと思ってとても感銘を
受けました
さあ皆さんここで思うのは何でそれが日本
にいなかったのっていうことだと思います
でもちょっとお待ちください
皆さんにお伝えしたいことがもう一つあり
ます
今さっき
男性のリーダーでもこれを考えることが
できたっていうのが一つのキーだと思って
います
私の活動ですごく多彩になっている一冊の
本がありますそれは日本で初めて生理費を
作った会社の
課長の話です
その
課長はもともと
整理用品なんて携わるつもりはさらさら
なかったんですが
社長の命令で
新会社の整理用品の
メーカー設立に携わるんですねで彼はその
仕事をしながら
女性たちが今どのように
整理をに対処しているのかそしてその彼が
調べた結果
女性の生命の対処は
ゴムみたいなふんどしみたいなのつけて
出し麺をまたに挟むっていう結構もう
ひどいものでそれにとても胸を痛めてい
ましたそして
彼は
言うんです
オフィスは銀座にありました銀座の街を
闊歩します
銀座には
美しく化粧して素敵な予想をした方が
たくさんいますでも彼女らが
外気温そんなに聞かざいながらも
自分のプライベートな部分がとても粗雑に
扱っているそれがとても惨めだというふう
に言っていましたでもそれが女性たちの
責任
等は言えないとも言っていましたそれは
長い間
生理の
社会的地位がとても低かったからなのだと
私はこの本とても
衝撃的でしたそれまでは
男性って
生理がないからわからないよねって思って
たんです
わかってくれなくてもしょうがないよねっ
て思ってたんですがその方の中にわかっ
てる人がいたんですということは何か
わかるような形にして男性にデータを
見せることができれば
きっとこの課長のようにわかるんだなと
いうふうに思いました
そこで私はいろんな企業に協力をいただき
ながら実証実験を行いますそのうち最初の
実証実験は
都内の5社で行われたものでした
その結果がこちらです
ほとんどの方が
生理になった時に生理用品を持ってなかっ
たら
困ったという回答をしています
で皆さんこれ膝のデータだと思うんじゃ
ないかなと私は思うんですが
実はこの定量的なデータでは
企業は動かせなかったなっていうふうに
思っています
実際にこの実証実験を終えた後に整理料金
を設置し始める会社が現れました
その会社で何があったかっていうと実は
男性の関与があったんです
女性たちが
当たり前に我慢しなければいけないと思っ
ていたこの制御の現象
男性たちの方が
すごくピュアな目で見れます
女性がこのデータを見ながらや本当に生理
になると思ってなかったのになっちゃった
時ってほんと大変なんだよねっていうこと
を
ポロッと口にしたその真実が
男性の心を
打ちます
えーそんなに困ってんの
生理用品がないってそんなに大変なのえ
すぐに使わなきゃいけないの
えっそれだったら
置いてあげようよ
その言葉が
企業立ちを動かしてきたなと思ってます
なので私が検証した中では大事なのは
データでもないんですコミュニケーション
なんです
さてここで
男性も女性も
友に関わる必要があるというお話をしまし
たこの中で海外の事例をご紹介しましょう
私が今生理用品の設置において一番
うらやましいなぁと思っている国がインド
です
インドでは
西洋品を
初めて作った男性の
実話がありましてそれが映画化されてたり
するんですけれどもその関係で生理費を
いろんな学校とかオフィスに置こうって
いう動きが大変活発です
でそのニュースを検索するとなんとですね
生理用品の
ケースディスペンサーの周りを取り囲んで
男性も女性もみんなが
置いたぞっていう顔をしてるんですね
これすごくいいと思いました
そして大事なのは清涼品が置かれることも
大事なんですが
男性も女性もいろんな人たちがその場にい
てこれが
みんなに必要なものであるということ
誰か特定の人に対しての問題じゃないと
いうことそれをに市民権を与えるという
ことが一番大切だと思いました
さてじゃあそれを日本ではどのように考え
られるのでしょうか
私は
過去に
清涼品ケースを作っていましたでその
ケースは実は地球環境に優しい素材で作ら
れてたんですけれどもちょっと壊れ
やすかったんです
なので私は
工夫としてそのケースに目をつけました
目をつけることで女性たちがもうちょっと
あの
優しく扱ってくれるかなというふうに思っ
てたんですねで
実はこのケースにはですね
中身が見えるように
穴もつけましたそして取り出し口をつけ
ましたそしたらどうですか
皆さんこの顔を私すごい間抜けで可愛い
なって思ったんですでまぁもともとは女性
がこうあの使うためにこれを
作ってたわけなんですけれども
でもこの顔だったらちょっとなんか男性陣
にもコメントをもらうことがありました
なんか
間抜けで可愛いねとかなんかあの
親しみやすくていいですねとかそういう
意見でした
で私この
愛で
発明だと思ったんです
今まで私たちはこの一人一人1対1の
コミュニケーションだと生理用品の話って
とても難しいですなぜならばとても
センシティブだからです
なんですが
実はこの物を挟むことによっていろんな人
たちが自分の個人のエピソードとは
関係なく話をすることができますそして
間抜けな顔してるねとかこ
れってどういうふうに使うのとかこれが
あると便利なんだよねっていうようなこと
を
言うことができます
このように
言いづらい話ってあります
だけど
物を介することでこの話ができるそういう
サイクルを作れることがあるんだなという
ことに私は気がつきました
さて皆さんいかがでしょうか
こういう言いにくい話
他にもあると思いますでもこの対応はいつ
までもしなかったら100年
続く可能性があります
どこかで送電さは断ち切らなければいけ
ません
皆さんの身の回りでももし
言いにくいなぁでも話した方が
みんなと一緒にやっていけるなそういう
ことがあったらぜひ何かちょっと工夫をし
てみてください